today i'm going to answer your questions
on career and consulting topics
on my instagram channel firm learning i
recently asked you
to submit the questions that you want to
have answered by me
already directly answered many of them
on my instagram channel but still there
were some questions that
many people asked and i want to use this
video to answer these questions for this
broader audience because i know and i
trust that many of you guys are asking
yourself the same questions so welcome
to another coffee break here on my
channel firm learning
my name is heinrich and here on my
channel firm learning i want to help you
to become successful in the first years
of your career so i will now always read
out the questions here on my phone
and the first question is can non-native
germans enter into mckinsey and germany
with c1 level german and here questions
like this now always i will answer with
a more general type of approach so not
talking about specific firms but rather
for instance mbb firms in general and
the answer here is that
yes you do not need to be a native
german to work at a german
mbb firm and this is true for most other
european countries as well
indeed the two requirements that will be
required from you
are first that usually you will need to
have a valid work permit a valid work
visa
to actually be able to work in the
country and second you will need to have
local language skills so not necessarily
on a native level but at least on a
business proficiency level
so c1 should usually qualify for that
next question
is it worth doing an mba even though i
have a phd and three years of consulting
experience
and here now i want to generalize this
to the question is it worth to do an mba
right especially if you already have
lots of academic experience
and here i'd say it very much depends on
your goals
so usually just to advance in your
career i do not think that an mba is
necessarily required however when mba
can help you is to make a transition in
your career
so whenever you feel like you are stuck
in a specific area in your career
then the nba is like the joker card that
you can pull out
once in your life and that can really
help you to make that transition
and already once made a video about that
how exactly this works
i will link it somewhere about field so
check it out to learn more about this
is it possible to get into mbb with an
extremely low
gpa and i have three years of experience
so let's just say it will be extremely
difficult especially if your gpa is
really low so i'd say if your gpa maybe
is average but not super stellar then it
already will be tough
but probably you can compensate that if
some other parts of your profile are
really stellar but if your gpa is
really low then again i don't want to
say it's impossible maybe if you're
really a genius a superstar and this
comes true through your application by
other areas of your profile
then maybe you have a shot but for most
people i consider it
really difficult and probably
unfortunately not realistic how would
you go about getting an internship at
one of the big
four consulting firms and here i don't
think there's some kind of magic trick
that you need to have right and what you
need to understand is that these firms
often have highly professional
recruiting processes so while of course
it might help if you already know a
consultant and he can then directly
forward your application to hr
you should be able to assume that with
these firms you can just apply via the
online form and your application will be
treated professionally and if you
fulfill the criteria then you will be
invited and indeed when i applied to nbb
i always just use the regular
application
form i didn't have any insider contacts
in these firms and this worked out
really well for me
and it will work for you as well if you
fulfill of course the criteria
how hard is it to get a mckinsey after
your bachelor and indeed not
generalizing it not for all the mbb
firms so usually you can assume that if
you have a bachelor the hurdles to get
in
are pretty similar than if you have a
pre-experienced master
therefore it can be a bit tougher to get
in with only a bachelor
because the criteria against you are
measured and very similar compared to if
you start with a master but as it will
be one or two years earlier in your
development both from the personal side
but maybe also from the internships that
you have completed you will need to have
achieved
more in the rather short time span of
the bachelor to be invited to the
interview and then to get in therefore
it's not impossible but yes i guess you
can
argue that it's a bit more challenging
our mba is
mandatory to get into mbb no not at all
this is
not at all mandatory and especially in
countries like germany
mbas are still quite uncommon just most
people don't do an mba
so people are regularly hired at mbb
firms without an mba but even in the us
or other countries where mbas are more
common you can absolutely start with a
bachelor with an undergraduate degree in
a business analyst position and you will
get in
in an mba by no means it's a hard
requirement what is the best book that
i've read
recently so here i can recommend you to
check out my book recommendations you
find a link to that below in the video
description they are linked to a page
with all the books that i can really
recommend
and of course some of them i've also
read recently do you think there might
be a valid reason to go for
tier two instead of a tier one so here
of course people might have very
personal reasons to choose certain firms
and of course personal fit might play a
role as well but i believe that
for most candidates there's not really a
reason why you should join in here too
if you have the opportunity to join a
tier one and the reason is that in terms
of work life balance in terms of overall
working experience they are quite
similar but in tier one firms you will
often have the opportunity
to work for slightly more relevant and
important projects also the support that
you get via the whole back office
infrastructure is larger so you can
focus
more as a consultant on the key
consulting topics and lastly the brand
value for your cv but also your exit
opportunities after your work will be
slightly better
in tier one firms compared to two firms
this is at least my opinion what are
advantages or disadvantages of
doing a master and here i think the
answer is pretty similar to advantages
or disadvantages
of doing an mba and here i also did a
video about that i will link it
somewhere here above but in general the
cost of doing a master are twofold first
it's an investment of time and second
it's an investment of
money so you need to ask yourself
whether these two types of investments
are worth it the investment of time will
usually be compensated if you're able to
start one step
higher if you start in the workforce
with the master compared to a bachelor
and at least for all the consulting
firms this is usually the case
usually you start one level higher with
a master
and therefore you can compensate for the
loss of time by already being one step
further ahead in your career journey
especially if you work in a private
university you will need to pay student
fees
but then the second factor of it is also
that in this time
you will not earn money right so you
miss the salary so this of course can
add up to quite a high sum but again if
the master opens up career opportunities
for you which might have not been
available with your bachelor or maybe
also the knowledge that you acquire via
your master will then really help you to
be successful in the long term then this
might easily be
overcompensated throughout the lifespan
of your career so keep these two things
in mind but my personal opinion is that
if you do a master at a target
university with good grades
usually this will be worth the
investment in the long term in most
cases
what do i do for a living did i quit
consulting enough yes
why so yes i quit consulting about a
year ago i worked with mckinsey but now
left the firm
since then and the reasons i detailed in
another video where i talk about what
things
are that i didn't learn in consulting
and i will also link it somewhere above
so overall i'm super grateful and
thankful for my time at mbb it was an
amazing experience and i do believe that
consulting is a great career choice for
many young business graduates out there
but still i've heard that after these
years i wanted to do something slightly
more operational so i joined a german
retail company
in a cto position so i'm working on this
new career since about a year
and of course in parallel i know also
started this youtube channel if you have
more questions that now were not
answered here in this video feel free to
leave me a comment below in the comment
section
and i will do my very best to answer
every single one if you took
any value out of this video at all
please smash the like button for the
youtube algorithm
and also subscribe to this channel to
stay up to date on my content i release
weekly videos
every single saturday if you want to see
even more from me and potentially also
contribute to future q a sessions
you can follow me on my instagram my
handle is firm learning and i also have
a mailing list you can find a sign up
link to that mailing list below in the
video description
i want to take a moment also thank all
the sponsors of my channel
without all of you guys it wouldn't be
possible what i do so
thank you so much and if you are
thinking about becoming a sponsor as
well
and get access to some great member only
sponsor only perks
you can sign up via the join button that
is next to the subscribe button so have
a look at that i'd love you to become a
member and i would be super thankful for
your support so big thanks to all of you
for watching i very much appreciate it
and i see you again
next saturday bye